the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody to the 2022 summer
chess classic here at the st louis chess
club i am grand master alejandro ramirez
to bring you all of the action with my
good friend grandmaster christian
carrillo alejandro always the pleasure
to be here casting the games of some of
the best chess players that we have here
on the ground in st louis we have two
amazing events uh 10 players at the
start unfortunately we have some news
tell us about that yeah unfortunately
both of our tournaments are down one
player let's start uh by seeing what
happened and unfortunately to ray robson
he is participating in group a but just
before the start of his round number
four he did test positive for covid and
unfortunately had to withdraw from the
event because he withdrew before the
half point mark his results against
eugenie o'byrne and misha are a note
that means that everybody gets deducted
whatever they scored against robson and
no points are awarded for his opponents
on the remaining games very important
yeah this is very important and it's
very different than our situation in
group b we'll get to that in just a
second but let's take a look at the
standings in group a alejandro we have
tied for first position benjamin gledura
and yu yang yi with three points a piece
but let's not forget benjamin gledura
actually did not play against ubra
robson jonas bier abhimanyu mishra and
sam savion are tied for the third
position with two and a half points a
piece around hakobian and nicolas
theodore on two points gregory oparion
on why and a half and elias mirin on one
point and tell us a bit about the
situation in group b alejandro yeah very
unfortunately we had a similar system
where we had to withdraw a player
unfortunately this is not confirmed to
be coveted we're not saying it's that
unfortunate player is sick
so he had to withdraw from the event uh
because he withdrew after the halfway
mark his results with cheka dragoon joe
harutinian and antipov are still valid
but he will forfeit the remaining games
now of course it doesn't mean that he
loses reigning for those games he will
just stay neutral uh but his results so
far do count not only for raiding but
also for the tournament standings a
little bit unlucky for the players that
he has already played especially for the
players he's already beaten but this is
how chaz works yes unfortunately cheka
will have to take that loss and
everybody else that is due to play him
in the remainder of the games will get a
full point now let's take a look at the
standings in group b tied for first we
have guillermo vasquez and jj alimarandi
we three and a half points apiece in
soul third position we have camille
dragoon with three points tied for
fourth position that's a big tie we have
zu zhanchao mishantipov brandon jacobson
who unfortunately is no longer in the
event christopher eu and john burke and
in ninth position soul ninth position we
have tigran harold union and in seoul
10th position the unfortunate nico check
out with only one point now tell us
about the tournament format alejandro
it's pretty straightforward we have two
10 player well now 9 player round robins
with a classical time control of 90
minutes for the first 40 moves 30
minutes for the rest of the game and a
30 second increment throughout very very
traditional and similarly traditional is
our schedule one round a day one p.m
start for every single day except for
the last round that we start on friday
at 11 a.m and that is to accommodate a
potential playoff in case that we need
to break the tie between the winners of
the tournament and we are on social
media we are online join our
conversations we are on twitter at
hashtag summerchessclassic and of course
we're also on youtube and on twitch join
us on the chat i'm keeping an eye on it
it's already quite active and i am
looking at it guys so don't think that
i'm not and as a reminder for everybody
that is following us on youtube ad on
twitch for every 75 dollars that we get
on donations on bits on subs we'll be
able to provide a full semester of chess
programming for our students here at the
st louis chess club imparted by some top
level grandmasters the st louis chess
club has great initiatives some of them
which bring players from the very
beginning of chess classic chess all the
way to the top the sinkfield cup and the
us championships passing through the
summer chess classics so all kinds of
chess are here but we need your support
those 75 really go a long way that is
just uh an incredible sum for only 75
dollars you get a child through a
semester of the best tutoring that there
exists here in the united states you
have coaches such as volusia nacobian
you alejandra i know you've been doing
some of this as well it's just an
incredible mission that the saint louis
chess club is putting forward now let's
talk about the pairings in group a what
games do we have it seems like benjamin
gledura versus aram hakobian as well as
elias smirin versus nicolas theodore
have already finished in a draw we only
have two more games spending the one
between gregorio parrin and abi manu
mishra as well as yu yang yi versus sam
savion and that in fact
is the key match-up in group a as we can
see yu yangi one of the leaders of the
event going into the sixth round he's uh
playing at the white side against
another 27 plus player sam sevion a
player that's just been rising and
rising in the past few months
unfortunately he was unable to break the
ice in this tournament but definitely in
this one a tough matchup against you
young yeah that's a great match up to
2700 is facing each other it's not
something that happens very often in
chess outside of super early events
whether it be the world cup sing field
cup something that has a really major
gravitas to it so we're lucky to have
them here at the summer chess classic
they're certainly excited to play some
of our players here in st louis and
savion has been one of those players
that's risen through these events being
able to play some really top-level
players and look at what kind of players
we attract yu yang yi who has played all
over the world playing against the best
of the best such an established
top-level player absolutely and he's
happy to come here and play he actually
requested to play this event uh he had
heard about it and he contacted us
instead of the other way around
yeah i mean
to be honest we never kind of expected
to be able to get you young in this
tournament such a tough player 27 plus
he has been actually over 27 60
alejandra at one point in his career and
i remember him from when i was young a
decade ago when i played in argentina
and he was there he was only a low-key
24 50 2500 level player and then he
immediately went into the stratospheric
27 plus level now
what do we have in that position
alejandro let's uh take a look at it
let's try to analyze it a bit it's hard
to say for me at the moment we're not
using engines in this analysis because
well that's how we feel like and
at the moment it seems that
white has the pluses even though black
has the pair of bishops
uh it it seems that white could
eliminate that pair of bishops whenever
he feels like with knight takes e6 yes
currently he also has the control over
the c file
and
let's be honest black the bishops are
not very good no no no as of now the
bishops are not very good and to be
honest i don't see any uh prospects
short term or long term for the bishops
at the same time
you have a beautiful night on d4
blockading night we know that tonight
blockading is probably the best piece to
do that job but at some point it does
seem like you will likely have to take
on e6 or allow
potentially the bishop from e7 come to
c5 and then take on
a d4 i have to say it definitely feels
like white has the initiative whether
that's enough to create any sort of real
problems for black
we shall wait and see we like white we
don't know if it's enough for an
advantage but we would definitely take
white in this position let's let's
continue with the b pairings just and
we'll come back to this game because it
is quite fascinating we'll be spending a
lot of time on it uh in the b pairings
well christopher you gets a full point
forfeit win against brandon jacobson
remember because we already crossed the
halfway mark doesn't count for raiding
though so no rating change there ghetto
vazquez one of our tournament leaders
has already drawn his game against
nikoca who hasn't been able to really
find his form in this tournament and i
think certainly the game of the day has
to be this last pairing jj ali miranda
against kamel dragoon because this could
change up the leaderboard jj is
currently the leader with guillermo both
of them are three and a half out of five
and camel is the only player that is
half a point away from them in striking
distance uh a win over for black in this
game would actually catapult the polish
player to first place oh absolutely and
actually guillermo already is in seoul
first position because he's drew he drew
his game four points out of uh six right
now jj alimorandi with three and a half
he saw the result he knows that he has
the white pieces against a very worthy
contender that is camille dragoon and
let's see what's happening in this game
we're going to jump right into the
analysis because we have quite a tense
end game i have to say an end game with
a lot of pieces still left on the board
nevertheless
it does feel like
it's probably going to head towards the
draw
yeah it just seems like materials to
reduce right
it does feel like it so of course you
see knight takes e5 and i do believe
that you probably have to take that
bishop if you don't then you might have
to worry about rook takes g3 that is a
threat right now in the position knight
takes c5 knight takes c5 actually
before we get into this i have a tricky
what if i do knight f2
knight f2 okay i see what you're trying
to do so if you go rook takes g3 now you
go knight 24 3 4 very nice this works
right it does yeah you take take okay i
mean
i'm not sure i'm winning but right
at least you're an exchange job and you
can claim that you have some pool
it's something it's something yeah i'm
not really sure i even claim i have a
pull after routine too but i understand
that this this kind of works rook g2
bishop c2 right ah
i can still pressure then i do some
pressure then i do like this then maybe
92 is kind of a tricky move and he's
actually played a third he played rook
to f3 with you know similar idea just
try to create some immediate threats so
attacking the pawn on f5 h5 played
quickly actually was the response now
the battle is obvious right we're
battling um
this weakness against this weakness
right yes bishop to c2 most likely is
going to come on the board and try to
reinforce
the threat of knight takes e5 followed
by rook takes f5
how
would a black defend against that and
we see none of the players actually are
right now at the board one of those
curious spectacles i think you move the
bishop back you have to sing d6 probably
d6 is defended we like defended pieces
um also the bishop on d6 is nicely
controlling the knight right it's a
really nice geometrical motif right the
bishop three squares away from the
knight controls all of its squares
and yeah
it feels like white is pressing for the
advantage just because the king on f6 is
a little bit weaker
but
i don't think it's quite enough material
to really put any pressure right so
let's see how do we do it knight to f2
this was the move that you were
recommending with the idea of 94 84. but
it is a clumsy move in this move order
right
it does feel like it because
even knight e5
cannot be worse for black knight than i
take
94 i can take on e4 and just claim that
this is going to be a drawing some some
crazy look at 594 but i couldn't make it
work rook takes e4 rook takes f5 rook
takes f5 yeah i couldn't make that work
either yeah yeah
it never works even king e6 you're kind
of wondering if i actually expected
seven yeah yeah material is pretty it's
pretty reduced uh
it's pretty reduced so we're gonna call
this a probable draw absolutely
um well alejandro actually these players
are playing for quite a handsome prize
fund as well let's uh take a look and
see what we have in group a well that's
a beautiful number right there 22 000
total price fund with six thousand
dollars going to the victor of the event
four thousand dollars second place
completing the podium in third place
with three thousand dollars going all
the way to one thousand dollars for last
position and in the b group what do we
have there alejandro it's almost half
but actually a couple of the prices are
higher
higher than half second in particular
for some reason not two thousand it's
2500 but you know i don't think the
players in the b group are complaining
uh fourteen thousand dollars for them
which is still quite uh quite a bit uh
especially where players at this level
don't usually have the chance to win a
big open tournaments or play in the us
chess championship tournaments that have
these higher price runs this certainly
allows them to be able to travel and go
to different events and don't forget
that we cover all of their expenses here
for these events so uh they're kind of
uh free rolling oh absolutely absolutely
well not all the expenses i think most
of the xbox most of the expenses yes
absolutely now
what game should we focus on alejandro
let's uh you know what the funny thing
is there was there was a um
you've been watching i've been watching
but there was there was one round where
we finished commentary and there was one
game that was finished yes and this one
we started commentary and already like
four of them four games are finished
which is kind of funny this is an
unusual scenario actually the b group is
bringing it uh i i think burke
joe jian ciao has some potential okay to
sharpen okay this is a very typical
night or
type of positions
in which the opposite color bishops
instead of being boring and dull
actually make the game very exciting
because both kings castled on different
flanks
mean that one side is clearly pressing
against the other because your attack
will be faster and your bishop whether
it be the dark square bishop on f6 yep
cannot control the bishop on g4 or the
other way around the bishop on g4 cannot
control the bishop on f6 so if black
gets a good way to coordinate the queen
and the bishop against the pawn on b2 it
might spell disaster but similarly as
you're drawing arrows if white is able
to coordinate light scored bishop and
queen that might spell disaster for
black instead get the bishop to d3 the
bishop on g4 right now is not doing much
uh outside of just simply defending the
weaknesses the pawn on h5 as well as the
pawn on f3 potentially i would like to
get that bishop all the way back to d3
as you can see pointed out by the arrows
and then follow it up with creating this
battery along the p1 h7 diagonal put
some pressure on h7 now as you're
mentioning alejandro this bishop on f6
is already nicely placed to create some
havoc against the white king in case the
b file opens up or in case i manage to
either get the queen to d4 or e5 and
create um this
battery as well now
what's the next move the question let's
analyze this concrete really right the
the bishop on f6 is completely stuck i
mean the only move it has is bishop e7
but we obviously don't want to play that
if the bishop goes anywhere bishop e6
just wins right that'll end the game so
the bishop is in kind of a pin uh so for
example if you go bishop e5 try to
attack the queen bishop to e6 this is
the idea the fact is that you have to go
to h8 and now this just allows us to
deliver the checkmate um and h5 does
have somewhat of a threat potentially h6
right i like how our cameras are always
hiding behind the wall yes we're hiding
like we're hiding behind the wall what
why do we have these that's the spy
camera this is the spy camera i like it
i like the spike caps
so there are no cameras on the side of
the room so we actually rotated one
and we're doing the magic of television
so i agree with you i think this is a
state we have to keep this we have to
keep it we have to keep the spy cam i
think we have to keep this guy spy game
so what are you playing here with black
uh you do have the option of going for a
relatively sad end game with the move
queen d4
because
okay white could insist and play the
move queen c1 and prepare c3 but yeah
yeah not really sure that's what you
want to do nothing against it that i can
see immediately it doesn't feel right
but even the end game just doesn't feel
right probably something like b4 yeah
something like that doesn't feel right
at all so he played a5 actually none of
this will happen he he does point
towards the fact that he wants to play
the move b4 and as you were mentioning
alejandro the very good way to close up
this bishop and any potential against
the white king is to play the move c3
unfortunately right now it does feel
like c3 invites later on maybe not
immediately but later on b4 and that's
going to give me another hook
for uh my offensive on that's very true
yeah i still still even even considering
that i would still play c3 right
this was what i was uh
i was thinking about and here's where we
go right because i'll play h6 and then
we fight yes and now i go b4
wow and this is what we were talking
about how the game just kind of sharpens
very quickly right yeah yeah um
something can happen very quickly for
sure
yeah what if i just give you
eight
what if i take first of all you take
you're just taking back what are you
gonna take on g7 oh and g7 yeah if you
take on g7 i was actually thinking of
taking here i don't know if it works he
probably doesn't
but
i just wanted to see how it goes well
show me and the audience the mate
after queen f6
i think i see it
i'm not sure i don't know if it exists
because i see a check and then you hide
here and then you go rook b1 right you
do go rook to b1 but i think i run right
check check it out
check you run up
you keep running i think i keep running
right yeah yeah
i don't see it either
yeah
so maybe in this particular version
white gets in just a tad bit faster
you're escaping i'm escaping which is a
big deal so maybe you have to take
and if i go like this then you hide on
the others on the other side and because
i always threaten checkmate in one you
don't have to one more check no more
checks right and actually this is an
even easier version for you because
after rook to b1 you can take with the
rook yeah i can see the c3 is the center
is defended um yeah so quite interesting
okay you said this i said the b8 and you
said h6 h6 yeah taking advantage that my
rook is no longer putting some pressure
and defending the bishop on f6 yeah
um okay i see what you're trying to do
uh let's try to be a bit more cautious
as black even though
and this is why i felt like this rook to
b8 is a double-edged sword right um all
the time because you are
and you're abandoning the king's head a
little bit right yeah yeah so let's
let's try to go bishop to e5 yes and
then i'll still
play bishop b6 i want to throw in this
so i can take on g7 with chuck okay
that's okay i'll take with check
then i'll get back with the bishop
how many moves you need is the question
right made you right made me because i
don't know where i start but i think
i'll start with rook h1 sure do you have
an immediate
don't think i have an immediate mate i
don't think rook h7 works but i'm not
so i see a check but i don't take it
it's more than that
the thing is if you go here you have to
go up six yeah this is the only issue
give you one king h8 you actually get
made it with queen h4 yeah yeah yeah so
i will go up and it does feel like
any check that you're going to trouble
with the queen and you need to throw it
with a queen because if you throw it
with a bishop
then i get this extra square and that
might be by the way just a draw just a
draw yeah and i think it is just a
drawer bishop to f5 and then you can
repeat and then i can go back and then
if i try to go here
how is this just one check
you'll give a lot of checks i'll give
you a mate on d7 picture v6 yes
check
check
check
and mate
yeah yeah so it's just a draw
i think so yes so
this is just one of the many examples
and rook h7 obviously by no means forced
well i mean we're like 15 moves away
from where we started are you saying
this is not a completely forced
variation no
i don't think so
i don't think so otherwise trust would
be too easy um
a5 and right now
john burke is
pondering his next decision
which
again as you are mentioning c3 could
potentially be one of them
another one that i'm seeing
is just to play the move
h6
why not right away right
why not you still cannot move bishop to
g5 to try to take the pawn because after
bishop to e6 once again you get it so
um
what's the deal with this move h6 h6 i i
am
wondering
if you could play
no i don't want to play cheese no i
actually think he just wants to make a
draw i think he just wants to go before
wait
well if you take i go with i take with
the queen and then hopefully this end
game is a draw this end game should be a
draw but yes
should be but it's still well that's
yeah it's still always white that's
pressing a bit although here no right
here's just a draw
yeah and the thing is that you no longer
have the move queen c1 because i simply
take two and the problem is if you take
i take with a check right otherwise it
would be a check of me
all right funny game
uh yeah no absolutely funny game and he
did spend some time how much let's see
if he spent some time here 24 minutes
starting before this a5 move and after
a5 only 18 37 six minutes yeah that's
that's a long thing trying to figure
things out trying to see
what the best course of action is and
right now
you see what the problem is for white
and if you would have this extra vector
of attack
with a rule coming to g1
then that would make it so much easier
for you
unfortunately this queen is nicely
placed on c5 and protects this
against this rook to g1 move now i'll
just give you an example um let's go
something like this this rook to g1
forget about the fact that you can take
take on a3
now you would get ideas such as check
check
check
and checkmate right
another vector of attack you don't have
that if you don't have that then it just
feels
visually at least
that black should be with the inequality
range
i'm not going to be as bold as you are
to claim that uh i think this is a
position that would take me a long time
to
really decipher whether white is better
or not i wouldn't never think black is
better here ever no absolutely yeah
never yeah that would never cross my
mind but
uh
white being better definitely it
definitely rings some tunes now how to
do it precisely is a different issue
also why do you say that it's because
why do you say
black can never be better because every
time that you start your attack you
either do it by losing a temple with
rook b8 or you do it by allowing me to
trade the queens and in either case i
have a solid idea with the extra temple
i'll make you good idea with the
exchange of queens i'm just now worse
ever so this is why i would think that
in this particular position white is not
worse he's played a a kind of i'm much
more illiterate than you i only see that
this pawn is closer to the king
and i say okay white has to be at least
one tempo up that that's that's
grab master chest at the lowest chest
that's the way i see it i see the pawn
closer to the king yeah he actually
don't do that at home by the way he
actually played a move that i would have
never considered actually to be
perfectly honest we haven't considered
it
i'm looking through the analysis on the
chess and uh this is a completely new
move rook to d1
interesting
i like it i like it
creates an immediate threat
defend against uh rook takes d6 or queen
takes d6 probably queen takes c6 um
bishop e5 once again taking advantage of
the fact that this doesn't work bishop
to e6 would be a problem
um how do you defend rook to d8 right i
was thinking queen e5 actually
queenie five okay
[Music]
consequences
always look at consequences yes what's
that
the consequence of uh white's last move
rook to d1 is you no longer control the
e5 square so let's take advantage of it
i like it queen to e5 so i'm
more or less forced at this point to
take yeah i mean the only option is
queen c1 but then bishop g5 that's not
much of an option so
yeah so you have to take this is a
problem you have to take i have to take
with the bishop because taking with the
pawn is just unmiserable ugly it's ugly
very ugly so you take
and now once again it just feels like i
have to immediately put some pressure if
i want to claim that i have any sort of
advantage
and now you ah you do have this move
rook to b8 i do have rook b8 it's not
the end of the line if you follow it up
with bishop to b7 then i go b4 but even
even after a4 here
right so the idea being that if you take
take even this after b3 take you take on
b2 but you do have the move b3 which
would probably be
answered with bishop to b2 yeah but
black is not necessarily okay in that
end game no no no even though you have a
powerful protected passport on a3
it's much more valuable to have the
piece activity and
and that passport that's the passport
yeah also the difference of the rooks
right yeah which makes me think that at
some point maybe you throw in the move
bishop e6 i don't know where
but um
like at some point you throw in bishop
e6 just so that the king goes to h8
right not to uh not to f8 right perhaps
even earlier than this
like like
maybe maybe
yes i think here because you take both
pawns so here in rook d5 and if you take
on f3 i'll take on b5 thread m8 and i
take on a5 and that's just i think too
many pawns you haven't created a
passport yourself uh and i already have
one yeah
yeah yeah yeah
uh quick math quick math of course and
rook to b8
and then bishop d7 bishop d7 once again
now this is an improved version yeah
king further away from the center very
important
um
well yes queen to e5 might actually lead
to a better end game for white i agree
so we start looking at other resources
but rook d1 does ask a very
important question it's a perfect
question yeah how do you defend that
pawn it's an important pawn
uh it's not so important for black all
right let's play a normal move right
yeah
uh
i lost my game where'd he go oh here
so rook d8
now i think i can play
something like h6 though
queen e5 maybe is even
there's no real difference is there
hmm
so what do you uh what do you do right
now you can still play this move bishop
to e6 i can't play bishop e6 can you
change d5 yeah or you can start with h6
it's such a beautiful position uh
at least visually because you have
absolutely everything protected yeah as
white everything protects each other
more or less right rook protecting this
pawn and h5 bishop protecting the rook
the queen protecting the pawn and
on this side unfortunately you cannot
get
yeah um black doesn't have some of the
typical annoying ideas like queen g1
queen c1 for example that weak sometimes
could be annoying it just doesn't exist
well you can also take the queen on c1
oh
good morning stainless
like 4pm
good morning st louis at 4pm that's okay
yeah so we think actually that
burke's doing great in this position
right yeah yeah
well
he has an advantage he has an advantage
we don't know how good it is pleasant he
has a pretty pleasant advantage yeah we
like his position 19 minutes against 13
minutes and we have a bunch of other
games to uh to look at so let's take a
look haru the union versus antipov
well i like white's position a lot until
i counted how many rooks he has he only
has one he actually only has one rook in
his spawning heads too but
he does have the two bishops he does
have a clear target on e6
yeah
on the other side black does have a very
active rook on the first rank
nevertheless
i'm looking at the positions these two
bishops are so scary
yes bishops are pretty annoying actually
they're always extremely extremely
annoying and and very scary also very
difficult to play against from a
practical perspective
um
yeah rookie i think is a very normal
logical move it removes uh the rook from
the diagonal of the bishop and in some
ways to defend c-section yes
all right you definitely cannot take
with the bishop so you could consider
taking with the rook but the self pin is
pretty ugly i have a feeling something
will happen something will happen here
some some move like knight h6 might even
finish the game immediately
um although you have bishop g5 here
never mind
bishop to g5 yeah no but you don't i
don't because chuck and i take on g4
with you don't yeah yeah that's a nice
spot so yeah maybe not h6 just wins
because if you allow king f7 it's game
over
no way you survived that
so you could try to get away
no but it's not the move ah but because
now you don't have root weight one but
does does it work i take on g4
it doesn't
yes unfortunately yeah
but now i have rookie knight f6 ah you
think with the knight yeah i think with
the knight
geometry yes yeah
all right so this
after knight to h6 so if i go bishop to
h3 your point being that you're going to
go king to f7
is that correct is that your point
that's a good point
um
you're attacking this
if i move it you're going to get this
and the only way to not lose
something
major immediately is to go bishop to g5
but this is just a losing end game yeah
it's repeaters that lost b2
that's another pawn
completely lost all right so after okay
we i don't think you can take on e6 at
all the bishop needs to move no and if
the bishop moves and black gets to hold
on to his pawn on the e file
that's a different story that's a very
very big different story yeah
all right so let's see and it's actually
taking with the rook on e6 so perhaps
we're missing something christian we we
must be but maybe he's maybe he actually
missed knight which six i think he might
have missed nightwing h6 no no no this
is a strong player come on um it doesn't
matter he he played it fast he just
assumed that rookie six just worked
maybe maybe bishop f3
is there some kind of magic where white
plays bishop d5 and yes yeah yeah yeah
that actually exists
check yeah
but but once again let's start with
chuck i'm gonna give a check
let's give a check first check you go
here now i go here
how are you going does this change
anything
that's so annoying i'm not sure it did
although
so you have another check
but unfortunately i don't think it does
much came to g3 no
once again take i go rookie one now
okay okay okay hold on hold on all right
but but let's go back to we'll go a bit
slower a little bit slower here go king
f7
yes bishop d5 yes
and i'm wondering
can i play
rook d1
i could also possibly have played rook
a5 or rook d2 in the other variation
kind of ideas the point is that if you
move the rook i take on d5 and then i
take on e7 and i'm adjust up a piece
correct and if you don't move the rook
then i'll probably just take on e7
if you move the bishop i'll definitely
take on e6
and it's in
yeah yeah no this district that's it
yeah
this looks good
yeah yeah i think this actually works
oh wow oh wow perhaps he missed this uh
perhaps if you missed the rook d1 or
something right
big moment right now uh rook takes e6
knight to h6 we do think
that perhaps it actually finishes the
game
or at least gives black a decisive
advantage
well
wait wait wait wait wait a minute yep
no but it doesn't work once again you
give a check yeah yeah i was looking at
bishop f6 uh which controls a1 but it
has the issue that after knight takes g4
yeah we looked at
we looked at it yeah we looked at it
with this blue order yeah
yeah nothing works because um
unfortunately i take back with the night
yeah i am yeah i don't i don't see it
i have to say
is the time to cheat because
we just think it's winning right sure
let's uh let's cheat let's cheat a
little bit so we're actually going to
use the engine we don't use it very
often and we are actually right
completely winning we're right
sometimes sometimes we're right
occasionally oh and it is the whole line
bishop f3 rook a1 king f2 king f7 bishop
d5 k1 only like this and we found it
we're good guys i'm actually very proud
of this one yeah
i mean we saw it and
a 2550 level player did not see and he
played the rook takes c6 immediately now
let's see
misha is definitely good when it comes
to tactics that's one of his uh strong
points
would you consider him a tactical player
how would you consider michonne people
oh you're a trainer for sure a tactical
player yeah yeah you're very tactical
he's quite complete but when he's in
shape he's a complete player yeah when
he's not he has some some weaknesses
that i'm not going to disclose to you
alejandro
because i know you're taking notes i am
definitely taking notes but misha has
always been a very impressive player
actually qualifying to the super finals
oh yeah of the russian championship uh
was it 2021 or 2020 2020 i think 2020
and very unfortunate that he actually
had to withdraw like the most
unlucky time
to get covert because of uh because of
covid yeah no i mean um
that's the thing he fluctuates a lot
yeah he can go um he was before over 2
600 a few years back and then he dropped
back to 25.50 now he was also a couple
of years ago and even last year he was
over 2600 26 20 26 25 and now he's back
to 25 90.
that's the thing he fluctuates a lot he
can win 20 rating points in an event
against the strongest players on the
planet he can lose 20 ratings in one
event against 2500s
he's that type of player
and i'll tell you a funny story about
him all right
we actually played this online
collegiate competition okay if you
remember correctly and um
if i'm not mistaken if exactly in the
finals against you
okay again st louis university okay or
in the qualifier i don't remember but it
was quite important
that he played yeah his son was born
and he was playing from the taxi
on his phone
from the taxi and he got to the hospital
and his son was born while he was
getting a medal
so uh
you know
i i he has full commitment to the team
and i appreciate that
that that is commitment that i have man
i thought it just gave him the week off
that is full commitment to the team
no yeah oh you got to play you're gonna
have to play you gotta
you gotta make those moves man those are
world championship uh medals you know
yeah that we got that time yeah oh that
was a good weekend we both got our world
championship medals yeah
yeah good collegiate weekend um you guys
won the blitz and we won the rapid right
the other way around yeah yeah yeah we
want the blitz we want the blitz and you
guys wrap it up
quite um quite a big wait by the way do
we have any other no there's no other
way night which you can also start with
rook2a1 though it doesn't feel like it's
cleaner
actually this is cleaner
i like rookie one first because knight
h6 always comes with chuck now sorry
the threat of knight h6 comes with check
which is knight takes g4 so i don't have
to analyze for example to move bishop f6
anymore right or bishop anywhere really
right uh the dark square bishop can't
move you really really do have to move
this uh
sometimes this is uh such a difficult
decision to make you see two
good looking moves you see that they're
probably ending up in the same spot with
you completely winning
but
you start doubting yourself and you
don't know which one to choose right and
actually i'm we are looking at the
engine they're identical
yeah that's what we want in terms of
assessment in terms of assessment
yeah you spend a little bit of time i
think the hard part of the combination
is finding the move rook d1 oh yeah and
now that we have we are cheating i was
wondering why the move rook
somewhere else wouldn't work like for
example let's say that i play the move
knight h6
bishop f3 unless i don't throw in this
check and i just go immediately for the
move king f7
no this was uh yeah king of bishop d5
and then rook d2 what is the difference
rook d2 now well yeah because if you
have some bishop g5 right
bishop g5 recognition bishop b4
what
rook do you want but what if i take on
and now the bishop defense ah
that's not that's the reason why not
bishop g5 and bishop b4 yeah you want to
put it on the light square so the bishop
can't attack the rook yeah yeah that
makes a lot of sense there's some easy
things to miss there's some easy things
to miss yeah absolutely not h6 played
your students found it i don't think he
was ever going to miss it no no no
knight h6 is a great move
this one looks over i think
if he finds uh rook to d1 yes let's see
what happens but he's playing knight
knight to h6 i don't think you play
knight h6 without fighting without
seeing d1 yeah yeah and perhaps this is
the moment when harold union is starting
to understand that he might have slipped
in this one yeah it's been a tough
tournament for him only uh on one and a
half points out of five yeah
yeah it's been a tough tournament for
and i think bishop to f3 is on the board
it's on the board so he has to play king
to f's i seem real k1 is the same okay
one first yeah does it matter no it
doesn't cannot possibly matter here
right
kf7 attacks both of your pieces
but then
bishop d5 then okay one ah but then
rookie one one
yes what am i doing no
that is that that's almost made actually
it matters yeah it matters you have to
play
rook a1 first and there it goes rookie
one first so that the rook
on d1 is out of reach of for that bishop
on and i think he saw it yeah
yeah when when he sees it he he
generally doesn't miss
yeah we're going to keep on this one
because it might it might be coming
close to the end of the game and i have
a feeling
he might just resign because i thought i
saw tigran look at his position at some
point put his like hands on his head
like the typical telltale yeah i'm i saw
a line where i'm losing what am i doing
against it yeah yeah and i i think
they're gonna go straight into it let's
see king to f7 oh we caught this one at
a good time actually we did yeah
and i think king f7 is coming on the
board
excuse me
and by the way while we were discussing
that this uh spectacular game we do have
a result and that is you yankee versus
sam savion which did finish in a draw
yeah not not the most exciting fight
unfortunately from the position that we
left it out too many pieces just got
traded yeah king to f7 by the way on the
board
um in that one and we're going to return
and uh let's see if bishop to d5 will
immediately be played at this point you
have
to at least pretend that you still have
a good position that's why you probably
saw rook to d1 and by the way that is
not the game uh that we see on the main
board right now let's go back to tigran
versus
misha
you have to pretend at this point that
bishop to d5 you played quickly because
there's literally no other move right
everything else just blunders the bishop
on e7 or the rook i guess yes so you're
you're pretty much
you're confined to playing that yeah
bishop d5 player
and the thing is
black's actually i think
in a terrible position if you don't have
the memory
no no that's that's right it's pretty
forced and ricky one played instantly
and
this is game over it's funny rook to a5
is also a move right but then you go
bishop g4 and this is the thing you
can't have that i was wondering about
that earlier why can't i go to k5 for
rook d2 but it's the whole thing the
rook on the dark on a dark square the
bishop would retreat it would attack the
rook and then you capture it yeah and
then actually white ends up up at you
because they're upon no
he found the right configuration right
now he's just going to end up in
a piece up end game in which um i think
it's pretty much hopeless i don't think
so i think i think white just resigns
here yeah yeah i think that the best
thing you can do is something along the
lines of rook to e3 and try to put some
pressure yeah i mean you can play bishop
g5 is i think i think technically it's
the it's the best you can do but bishop
g5 yeah you only lose a
yeah but the problem is that i take on
d5 well i'll take on e6 first
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
you're down there it's trying to go to
yeah
either from b1 or bc it really does not
matter it's just completely hopeless
which is why we think that he might just
resign yeah yeah yeah
all right very nice no absolutely all
right uh should we stay with this one
the expected resignation or his probably
depends how much time does he have
13 minutes
let's move on all right he might suffer
there for a little bit because
let's move on yeah he yeah he knows he's
dead
we've all been there he's uh
dejected about the situation on the
board right now we're going to move on
top tournament for him actually
very difficult tournament for him but
that is the risk you're taking when
you're going into this type of events
because you don't get any easy routes
yeah that's the thing about this event
right there's no easy rounds i've played
a couple of these myself and they really
feel very different from open events
where you lose a game especially when
you lose twice in a row when you lose
twice in a row in an open tournament
i mean you're pretty much guaranteed as
a grandmaster to an easier pair an easy
pairing a bounce back pair
a pairing that you expect to win with
white black grey green blue whatever
they put in front of you you you'll
you're expected to crush your opponent
but here you lose two games in a row and
you're probably playing somebody higher
rating than michonne you get misha
antipov you get you know camille dragoon
yeah you get there's no easy pairings
it's tough to recover it takes a lot of
mental fortitude to play all of these
events i i'm telling you i mean this was
uh my situation
three years ago actually in the last
invitational that i played um i only
scored like three out of nine and it was
just a disaster of a tournament for me
one of the worst tournaments i had in my
life but that was the the feeling that i
was getting yeah i was uh losing and
then
a lot of pressure was coming next round
right way the white with the black
pieces you know and when you start
losing one two games three games in a
row then your confidence level just
plummets and people immediately they
they like they sense it yeah they're
like this is this is the fish this is
the this is the guy that's playing bad
this guy just got lucky but he's not
playing well yeah and people really do
notice this during the events they
target you oh for sure yeah i know the
the sharks definitely smell the blood um
knight to c6 oh there you go the dancing
well that we have a great question on
twitch
why are all the most handsome chess
commentators in st louis
that's why you started dancing i see i
see alejandro i see alejandro very good
very good
all right uh well we're gonna move out
of this one
and let's go then to something we
haven't seen and by the way
we have the same color shirt for today
we finally matched we finally we we try
not to match every day but we took us uh
quite a few rounds but finally we got it
excellent very good excellent all right
style two getting back to the games
to the business at hand alejandra that's
why we get very well said very well said
all right burke versus uh zoo oh by the
way yeah they're going straight into
this except
they that john burke decided not to take
on e5 we also considered the move a4 uh
before we left left this game a4 was the
first instinct yeah it was the first
session we thought that rear k5 was also
good i noticed that burke also like we
said took the time to give this check
right took the time to give this check
on e6 force this king to h8
and then put the rook on d5 which which
gives him the best version of this end
game give it when the rook is still on
f8 yes because from g8 if you do allow
the rook to go to ba first then the king
can go to athlete another issue
one of the main issues for black in this
position is how do you get the king back
you could play a move like g6 but then
you give up on creating a pass pawn on
the king side because the bishop can
just cement f3 from g4 you really don't
want to do that but if you don't play
them with g6 at any point
you're just not getting your king into
the game exactly
so
we got all the way to this position and
rook to a 8 just came on the board of
course
natural move defending the pawn on a5
and this is by the way what we were
discussing right we consider this move
rook takes a5 because it creates
immediately a past pawn for white also
for black but it does feel like the pawn
on a3
not necessarily a liability from black's
perspective but a pawn that needs to be
protected more resources need to be
allocated to the defense of that pawn
right now because after looking to a2
and it just feels like yeah let's be
honest it's not going anywhere
no there's the a3 is not going anywhere
the problem is you the bishop b2 is not
really helping black defend against the
avalanche of pawns that is coming his
way yeah because b4 at some point in one
shape or another i wouldn't make it
worse you'll make it work you'll play
like bishop b5 or you'll play rook a4
even like b4 immediately yes uh you have
to calculate i mean before immediately
maybe bishop c3 but right right right
but you know you'll go so let's start
with king 282 right there's still no
good way of bringing the king even here
i would consider playing g6 h6
yes i will lose h6 but the moment you
pick that up i'll pick up a3
and then i'll just it's all about the b
and that's all about the b pawn it's all
about the b pawn um
all right what he's done is also very
tempting he's playing the bishop c6
attacks the rook the rook has a very
uncomfortable decision okay
so let's say i continue row k7 yeah the
thing about a move like real k7 is that
even the stupid move rp5 is not so easy
to make but f4 i think is actually just
just winning
and then
yeah
yep
that attacks
two things and if the bishop goes
anywhere else then of course d6 is
hanging that's a problem yeah
so you have to keep contact with the
bishop right
but
because right now even f4
f4
actually i calculated from a fart this
line and take take and h6 and you are
not forced because you have king james
that's the problem
yeah
so rookie six we think it's actually i
think we're cases or less worse yeah
if you don't go to k6 you're in trouble
yeah and just to mention that rook c8
rook takes a5 doesn't work for black
uh which one rook c8 instead of rook k6
oh because i just take yes
yes yeah fishes and actually rook to a6
and i see uh zhu actually shaking his
head right now what do you do after rook
to b5
i think you have to go king g8
i think you have to put on your uh
running shoes your running shoes
but it's very miserable because bishop
d5 rook b7 just for bishop d5 rook b7 is
extremely miserable for black
you have no moves exactly
wow that this is
oh my god that worked that rook is
actually going to get picked up by king
a2b 3c4 b5
oh i actually don't think i'm kidding i
don't see how to defend it well you can
go bishop before and try to save it like
this i think it's the only way in fact
ah you do right and i have rook a7 as
well rookie seven is important actually
i forgot about this move
it is a bit and he has played the movie
but he's he's not happy i can tell you
that much i mean nobody's happy i can
see it on his face nobody's happy with
this position
yeah we give burke huge winning chances
here yeah yeah
huge practical challenge huge practical
challenge even if the computer we don't
have no idea what the computer says but
just from a practical point of view it
it looks nasty nasty to play this
position yeah yeah so many weaknesses
the pawn on a5 the rook
the bishop doesn't really come in i mean
the king the king is yes that is the big
big problem in the position and speaking
of the king okay
no i cannot do that so rook to b5 i was
trying to make something like g5 or g6
work but
the thing about g6 or g5 is that i think
i will go ahead and h6 yeah especially
g6 especially
g5 h6 and maybe like this yeah but this
is just a better version for me because
i can go check immediately yeah king of
fade no bishop d5 i think bishop d5
bishop d5 to keep the king restrained
and then rook b7 and i'll take and this
is obviously yeah
yeah yeah yeah no this is uh
not good news for zhu zhan chao no this
looks like burke has excellent winning
chances
uh any updates in the matchup of the day
ali marandi against dragon well they're
repeating right now so jj has the option
of going knight d3
king f6 was some kind of weird draw
so
after rook to e1 knight to c6 knight to
d3 king to fc is getting off the pin
yeah knight to f2
threatening some sort of uh pin attacks
with knight to e4 followed by knight to
c5 targeting the pawn on b7 you have to
defend against that
and uh there we go knight to d3 if he
wants it it would be a draw yeah and we
didn't see much right we thought jj has
some pricing chances but material is
pretty reduced it is at the same time it
is him that is putting absolutely
pressure and he's actually chosen
something else so he wants to continue
the game uh he's played the move a3
makes sense to me uh i think he can take
the perpetual whenever he wants it he's
removing both rook b4 and knight before
his ideas he's giving king some flight
square on a2 and it passes the move
right it's your move sir make something
that doesn't worsen your position uh
good luck well this is what i was
looking at right because i'm trying to
weaken
the control of your position
for example rook to b3 was a tempting
option um mostly for the fact that once
you play the move b6 then knight on c6
doesn't have an outpost speaking of this
uh and people has won that game we did
expect resignation uh at the moment that
we left off that game and it didn't
quite happen there but it was close
enough no absolutely quite uh quite an
important game for him for the last uh
three rounds or so he's been on the back
no no actually misha
two games in a row and survived both
exactly that's funny so this is a big
break for him right now
how does that put him understandings he
goes to plus one plus one he's going to
plus one he was somewhere in the middle
of the standings with fifty percent so i
would assume he's getting
right now closer to to the leading pack
it's a tight group uh we've had had some
summer classics and spring classics
where one player kind of runs away with
it one of them was yours where you
started with five out of five yes uh but
there are other classics in which the
field
just keeps itself
more compact happens sometimes happens
in others
even in the sink field cup we've had
tournaments where they're very compact
and some tournaments where fabiano goes
7-0 so it does happen at all levels of
chess
but in this one this particular b group
is very compact plus one is good enough
to challenge for the leadership
absolutely yeah now plus one is a very
decent score right now um all right
so we have two pending games in this one
and we've just looked at them we just
looked at them so we have to go through
versus
michelle mishra it's the only thing left
right on the a group because we have a
draw the dura hakobian a draw between
you young e and sam savion and a draw
between smearing and nicolasiodoro this
is one and this one funny end games
it feels like white has all the space
but there's not much to do with it
not much to do with it it doesn't seem
like black's really suffering that much
here no no i mean white's better right
but right but how much better
not much and
the main point
at least the way i see it right now and
that's what i believe he played the h6
for is that if you do take and try to
invade on
g7 pick up this guy
i
even have this move that's an annoying
move
just like follow your uh that is an
annoying move yeah and just kick you out
you cannot take the planets again you
cannot even go to h7 that's the thing
you you don't need to calculate anything
you're taking f8 the rook has to go back
you go back to e7 and we make a draw
uh something that's it yeah this doesn't
doesn't seem very prominent no no h6
right now it does uh feel like grisha
obarin is trying to find his last
tries attempts in the position to
destabilize
black's defense misha chris he keeps
impressing uh he's just a very solid
tournament so far i mean he won his game
where he was presented chances found
chances against gledura yesterday
actually wasn't able to finish that game
off the only game he was worse in was
the game between him and beer
he got very lucky on that one he got
very lucky in and down but outside of
that a very clean performance so far by
abi manu just uh just drawings apart so
cleanly it is amazing absolutely
absolutely and as we are getting ready
to get misha on tip of uh to go for an
interview right now let's go back in
fact
to the b group and i'm going to
take a peek at this game between john
burke and zhu zhang chow because we were
looking at this position and
we gave john burke great chances to
break through and it does seem like he's
following the variations that we were
discussing rook to b5 threatening
checkmate on
b8 but as we go along and we will
get into the midst of this position we
do have a victor of today's round mihail
antipov mikhail welcome to the show
finally finally back to the show uh we
were just discussing you had quite a
difficult time in the last two rounds
you were down a piece against brandon
jacobson yesterday also against zuzonzo
but finally you broke through how does
that feel
it's a bit it's a big surprise to
finally win the game
i was watching it for almost two
tournaments because uh in summer in in
springfield classic
uh i didn't manage to win
any single game and i lost five so it
was
extremely disappointing also like as you
mentioned i had some troubles in
previous rounds and to be honest when i
played uh right against george and xiao
i thought that uh i'm winning after
previous sacrifices i missed bishop 5
idea for him
if he does not go bishop 5 it's quite
scary already and then i mean queen a5
was extremely strong idea for him yeah
so it was
small work for me now but i managed to
get a drawback in that one uh and we're
not going to pull that game up but just
to discuss it did you
know that you have some chances of
equality once you got that pawn on f6
queen to fa just defended everything did
you feel like it's a draw or were you
just as surprised as us that it was
actually it's quite funny but i didn't
even consider that i shouldn't be works
when i did not consider my g6 queen h5
i mean i can collect it with swine
because uh instead of queen a5 he could
go queen g8 yes when i go queen c3 f6
and you get always the same type of
position i was thinking about it for
like one minute and i thought i mean his
queen is paralyzed wow i always have
this
idea so probably it should be the other
one wow all right but uh
take us through today's round and the
critical moments of today's round
yes sure
i think
the most interesting part is the opening
because i decided to go for market swine
which is considered to be quite
scary for work
but take on the fourth white should know
it quite well for example my opponent
play bishop
uh which is considered one of the main
lines f3 is also possible to have almost
the same positions we had in the game
like knight d4 queen d4
bishop g7 bishop t3
castle queen g2 and now our idea is that
after a5
white can go for example as a b3 or
knight a4
so the point is that in this case paul
94 is protected right and
like my main idea is
is also possible for a5 for is main
energy of this one but uh it's much more
tricky right in this case because bishop
p2 is
i mean
it's a good move anyway but one of well
but still it's just a bit different
right
queen g2 so now after a5 you no longer
have
a way to stop a4 yeah and b3 is also not
working because of knight t4 and ryukon
a1 is handgun yes
so he played f3 yeah and finally he got
a4 in
i had this position several times in my
lifetime uh
and we see actually your game here
against greenberg he played b
yeah and also uh when i played against
graham in this one he played king of two
instead of rugby one i think it was
quite an interesting line oh yeah caron
on tip of 2017 yes it's quite tricky
because now for example if i go clean a5
uh rook ac1
b6 main idea of the line but after
knight d5
i cannot take on d2 because he takes on
the seven
and i'm down opponent right and uh like
to explain why do we need to play king
of two why not castle because queen
takes d2 doesn't come with chuck no no
what can castle oh instead of king of
two why it's a bit tricky as i said yes
because now queen a5 works its main one
rook c1 bhp6 and now knight d5 is no
longer working because i can take on g2
knight t7
king h8 bishop d2 and surprisingly
blacks survive and even play for an
adventure after hook fe-8
knight d5 knight takes d5 c takes d5
bishop takes and after bishop b5
we have a rookie five move
so it's a theory but
it's some sort of theory yeah it's it's
working
bishops and if you go bishop to c3
bishop a2 it's even worse for white
already because we have three discount
bishops and b2 is a serious weakness
excellent um he probably was aware of
this and he played this move knight to
b5
knight to d7 following this game against
you and uh
greenberg queen to a5 and you exchanged
knight to c7 were you still within your
theoretical knowledge at this point
i just know that knight b5 is
actually not a
serious threat for work because the
problem but even if i take only six we
cannot fight for an advantage i have
really good pieces and
his bitch.2 is always weak
right so i played this position several
times in blitz and rape it and suddenly
if white are not playing accurately and
they
try to pretend that we're playing for an
advantage we usually just lose right but
that's actually what happens all the
time right
so when did you feel like he uh he made
the big mistake in uh this position to
be honest i was i was surprised to move
f4 before all the way here yeah i'm not
sure if it's bad for white but i was
just surprised why he needs to go for it
because it was played in some sort of a
correspondence game
2018 because after knight f6
i mean at least he has some problems
already right
i mean if you cannot if you can just
play and not sacrifice a pawn why do we
need to yeah yeah it seems like um rook
fe1 was played in that game um but he
played the movie e5 and this does seem
to be losing a pawn take take rook to a2
immediately targeting the bishop on e2
yeah and suddenly i was surprised that
uh
this idea works
with
b3 rookie one because firstly i can see
that i just take an exchange
and
during the game i was shocked that he
could he could play bishop f3 here and i
was not sure if i can put some serious
pressure
because i think that i should yes
bishop to f3 seems to have been the best
movie in the position
it makes sense because now my boss pawns
on b7 e6 and hanging
and
probably i can't try to play for an
advantage i don't really remember what i
wanted to do but most likely white has
enough for uh equality some sort of a
dynamic equality yes yes sure
cool and we got to this point and he
almost i think immediately played rook
today i think when he played bishop g4
he just wanted it because bishop before
makes sense only if you take on the
secrets right
uh i think that i'm not sure what
exactly he missed but for example if i
go knight h perhaps zero to d one right
yes maybe he is two okay fun because
because if i go knight h6 for example
bishop of three in this position king f7
is not working correct if you go bishop
d5 right rook d2
and suddenly you cannot go rook to a1
because of
one and if i go hook g two is exactly
the same idea he has moved bishop before
g5 yes yes yes it's quite secret but
probably why it survives yeah and right
now the bishop actually protects the
rock on e1 yeah yeah we were actually
looking at this line we were trying to
understand what's happening and we
finally got to what you played in the
game as well um
and uh
when did you spot it when did you spot
this whole tactic whole sequence uh when
i played the knight f7 all the way from
knight to f7 so i was just considered if
i need to go into stone because i didn't
like bishop of three oh wow instead of
g4 quite a lot of moves ago
uh misha big victory for you with the
black pieces who do you have tomorrow uh
tomorrow i think i'm playing against you
you you that's uh going to be actually a
very difficult game not you young he but
christopher you we do have i was a bit
confused we do have a couple of views uh
in the event big game for you tomorrow
with the white pieces we'll let you go
get some rest get some preparation in
and we'll see you tomorrow see you
tomorrow awesome
perfect and
as we are getting
ready to check the other games as well i
i do come all the time back
to this end game between john burke and
zu zhang ciao
because it's such an intriguing end game
it just feels like white is so close
to a victory in this one i still don't
see it i still understand there's only
one weakness that we're playing against
right now uh it feels like the rook on
a6 is that weakness in a black's
position and i don't see the
breakthrough nevertheless it does feel
like white is somehow
and somewhat close to finding that the
final blow alejandro welcome back
welcome yeah yeah it really feels like
that this work is so so stuck
i don't think that there is necessarily
a killing blow right now
but
it comes so close right you're so close
to finding one that you really really
want to look for it yeah
i'm surprised about the previous move by
black the move h6 we
we were discussing bishop yeah we were
discussing bishop d4 here
with the idea of rook a7 and rook b6
trying to uh get this rook from a6 into
a more manageable position yeah but
he's not played it he's actually
thinking that he has the time to play h6
which by the way
it's not a move that i would have
thought is in black's plans right
because you're
creating even more weaknesses on the
light squares yeah
and also it's very it's even more
difficult to create a past pawn right in
any scenario in which somehow there
becomes a pawn race uh creating a pass
pawn with this particular configuration
it's as hard as it gets no
well you will have to sacrifice upon you
you have to sacrifice but in in the case
of pawn races because the pawn is all
the way back on g7 and h6 i mean i'll
queen my own g pawn right yeah
so
no he basically just says that i have
at least one extra tempe yeah now which
is it true or not we're about to see it
could be
it could also not be right uh well
imagine this the king already on b3 i
think that's like
i think i think if white were to move
king b3 i think you actually win by
force right yeah because after bishop to
d4 i came to c4 this is pretty good
which starts to beg the question how bad
is uh the position for black here after
bishop d4 he's played bishop d4 and i
was wondering i don't think it works
i don't think it works but i would see
me thinking of the move c3
that's how controlled black is in this
position to give up a pawn like this
yeah just for the tempo
just to get the tempo in and then you
have to get this bishop to this diagonal
to save the rook and the thing is that
here i couldn't find
although
let's let's keep going let's keep going
how uh how do we feel about this end
game is the same game yeah that's a good
question
it's not so
clear let's see
yeah you're going to have to give up the
bishop for sure
but uh
b7 you go here yeah perhaps you still
have enough as black
are you threatening g6 probably
that's the problem yeah you're just
threatening running g6 at some point
i'll be able to um i'm not in time no so
g6 you take
sure you will but i i don't think this
is enough
this cannot be enough yeah be careful
not to nothing and that's somehow yeah
and get this bishop blocked on this
diagonal okay yeah no it seems like he's
still within margins after the move c3
and that pawn sacrifice do we have
anything uh by the way white doesn't
have no no we were just trying to figure
out if we could like force the win right
which
this is the type of position this is
where you're starting to figure out if
the immediate killing blow works and and
it's it's responsible to calculate these
things because if the immediate killing
blow works there you want to finish the
game off when it's when it's due not
afterwards i have a funny idea let's go
let's see you're funny so i go here
all right i have no choice and now i go
here and the difference is that if i
play rook a7 here now i go king c4
i have my rook on f7 and i take with
check
and how do we feel they take i have a
feeling this is
not sure
yeah that h pawn is going at the h1 this
is the one way where like the h1
actually managed to become past right
yeah i was happy that my king gets fast
there but yeah i think that if the part
was on g4 we could seriously consider
this but you see you brainwashed me you
told me that black has absolutely no way
any pawn races
how bad this h6 move is great speech it
was a great speech i liked it all right
all right so we're going to have to find
a different way i mean i still thinking
b3 is a very logical move the thing is
do i want to play it before after i
throw in the chuck because here i don't
want to trade rooks i don't want to
allow your king to come out
and rook b5 doesn't seem to fully do the
trick
so i'm going to have to find something
more clever
that being said
oh yeah you still have d8 for the bishop
right that's the problem here i started
to think about whether the same game is
low yeah but i think i think you hold on
right
even though look at
black to move
there's no move you're going to lose
something yeah actually so something
that's and you lose something but you
might not lose the game right
right so you do give up this pawn right
yeah you give up you're going to go k8
something like that and now you just
stay like this this is an easy draw
actually i think so
yeah
easy draw easy draw yeah yeah you know
how easy but
it's probably easy i mean there is no
way to create anything i think
yeah i don't i don't see a way to create
anything really king c6
that's but i think i think you're just
thinking first of all i think you have
to probably take not only you can take i
think here i just when i go king b6 or
king b5 or whatever
and when you play bishop c3 i play
bishop b3 no but i go b3 first
but this is what i was wondering but
this is an easy draw right yeah that
should be easy enough i think so you go
here that's i i get it yeah yeah i'll
put my bishop on d8 but even this
yeah with a little bit of care
a little bit of care
probably bishop c7 just to be accurate
no no no no i don't need that all i need
is to get my king to b8
and i'm getting my king to b8
yeah if you would have the bishop here
you could give a check and that would
maybe be a problem yeah yeah that's true
but if i manage to get the king to b8 on
the dark square then yeah it should be a
draw it's a draw all right so we really
don't want to trade works that's why it
doesn't seem to be enough yeah
which means we have to search for
another path
and there's plenty of options there's
rook f7 rook f4
um there's even like immediately playing
rook d7
uh on the rook d7 king eight i don't
know why i did that and by the way he
made he just made move forward ah so
here burke will think for a while before
making a decision i think so too yeah
all right so ali marandi
lots of things have changed and actually
ali miranda is a pawn up wait what
happened
let's see all right so we left it off
after this move a3 a5 knight to d3
and not king f6 between d6 that's
surprising that's the problem well after
a3 you have these ideas of knight to c5
right which were not available before
that's right
why were they not available before they
were available but
you don't have a threat because knight
takes b7 rooked before ah yeah that's
the problem
but now without the barnes
covered in
you're in trouble i'm i'm going to
assume that what we said is true yeah
uh
king d6 takes stakes and we get into
this end game
where if black doesn't have an immediate
way to take on g3 which i don't think he
does no you go here i go here yeah um
there are some serious winning chances
here
no more than that
no no but this is yeah this is quite
serious i have yeah yeah it's serious i
wonder how real though let's say i go
knight c4 sure
check rick's e3 my ratio and the
differences
and here i'll go like
d5
yeah
i understand you're close
yeah black is close to making a draw the
idea is that i'm going to be active
enough to prevent you from are you from
doing this that question that's the
question right am i actually active
enough i think you're already in trouble
it might be i'm not saying i'm not i
really might be
yeah because 92 i go king c1 and now i
have a big threat yeah you have a huge
threat and the knight is kind of
dominating yeah it's very dominating you
can go knight to f1 i get it
you will take the pawn on g3 but i take
the pawn on p5 i'm going to give you a
check next move
opening up my pieces and um your king is
still cut
yeah no no big winning chances here i
don't think this works no
no no no bishop to c2 is on the board
and by the way they're at move 42 we
don't yeah there's not so much time
dragoons still have perhaps if we can
see a full shot of him
we will be able to discern how much time
he has
um
i don't see it
unfortunately i don't see it that's not
a good angle that pawn on a5
covering the
why did you play a5 yeah that was
probably the losing move
wow harsh for for good reasons
you cannot the clock
um
you you think white's really that much
better here rook d1 is a threat that was
a huge threat so i might actually just
win so i i think i think i have to play
with the game i think reggie two is the
well we have to look at right and look
i'm not saying no no no i get it the
chances are amazing right but
let's go back
10 moves ago when they were repeating
the position psychologically everything
was covered equal material limited
material as you pointed out
and suddenly
you're upon down yeah it completely
changes your psychology yeah it just
destroys you psychologically right it
puts so much pressure additional
pressure that you didn't have a few
moves ago maybe who knows camille maybe
at some point he thought that he's
playing for a victory
he had the more advanced pawn the pawn
on f5 it seems like the king is closer
to the pawn closer the action yeah at
some point you're playing for three
results like psychologically you're
playing for three years right now you're
playing for two results yeah that if
you're lucky i thought if you're lucky
yeah somehow my
my understanding of chess is that black
has technically enough yeah for
to make the draw yeah just because he's
so active to look behind the pawn and
there's such a reduced amount of
material right yeah but you got to prove
it you got to defend it i don't see how
to win the spawn on g3 anytime soon
which means that the game goes on and
the game goes on and the game goes on
and the higher
the chances will become to make a
mistake yeah
actually
just uh remembered
he was mentioning
mihail that this is the first victory in
two tournaments
this is the first victory
for
actually no never mind white hasn't won
a single game
in two tournaments for him he lost five
rounds five games with white in the
previous one no way he lost all his
white games he's lost all his right yes
and has and his first victory is with
the black pieces yes yes oh yeah he lost
all his wide games in the previous year
i guess i know what your lineup's gonna
be against us
can i be giving this guy misha with
black
black force bearing always that is funny
uh all right
wait what happened here
nothing nothing i think right e5
the king went to f8 and by the way this
is a game between uh grigori versus
abimanu the rook nicely defends the pawn
on 86.
king controls everything once again the
king is the only piece
actually i understand why he played this
move king to
f8
because if you allow me i'm going to
take on h6 and i'm not going to go rook
to g7 but i'm actually going to give you
a check and then we'll catch you and
then rook h8 and you don't have time to
defend kingpin so for example if you
make a move like this they take check
and now king to rook to h8 and i have
enough time to get
out after i take on h6
not only that but actually with the pawn
on e5 i also have the fc square yeah so
you don't want to suffer this you want
to okay king of f8 king 2f8 it's funny i
think if i played the move rook c2 here
you'd be in a lot of trouble but of
course that's illegal
jump
to c2 and just doesn't even allow me to
to draw an arrow like that
now how rooks work dude
yeah yeah rook to a1 was played okay one
but i don't i mean it doesn't have a
threat oh so i i think they're just
repeating right yeah i think so yeah
king 38 look to g1 king to f8 rook to a1
perhaps king 38 is going to come on the
board or king to e7 and then we're going
to see a repetition
um yeah i don't see any plan for white
no and it also doesn't feel like the
players are playing for anything at this
point anymore um
well
but even if you do get the rook to c2
yeah at that moment i think you are in
trouble okay so let's let's make some
bad moves for black just because we
can't find anything we're going to
create artificially
create stuff artificially
let's say i go with yeah yeah with the
king on f8 you know the worst situation
yeah this is the worst thing that could
happen to abhimanyu right king as far as
possible
this one might be lost though so you are
threatening to go here yes and that's
pretty quick since i'm not getting to c6
to stop you from going to c5 d4 and c5
after king to c3 you basically have two
threats at the same time i can only
defend against one
but you go the other way yeah you could
go to the king to the queen side
immediately with king d7 and you
actually hold on to your phones but i
think i break through on the on the
other side
oh you may know
here get to d7
and you do hold on but now you have f
yeah like f5 or something will will
break through upon
i could even start with b4 or whatever
wait but how do you do it uh before to
get my king 287 very interesting yeah
yeah very important actually
because now after f5 you take g6 and
you're not in time with the king on b7
you would be in time
with the king on a7 you're no longer in
time this is one of those studies that
you solve when you first start playing
chess yeah
that's what er your coaches give you
yeah basic fun end games yeah yeah yeah
no um so but this is the worst
incredibly theoretical yes
because the rooks cannot jump from a1 to
c2 that is not how chess works
and therefore there's no actual way to
get this configuration because the
moment you get the rook of the sec the
first rank i think rook c1 comes and
black has tons of counter play against
the other pawns so
that that was a good uh
analysis but it's not a nice tangent and
not realistic not realistic um
okay so rook to f2 was played by the way
we're going back to the other one we
don't think anything is going to happen
in the game between nobody and uh
abhimanyo i'm just going to turn on to
make sure it's true
it's zero zero zero zero it's zero zero
zero but not as zero zero as i expected
actually huh
so if you go king to e7 is uh you have
some problems yeah i guess
king e7 actually runs into g6 but i'm
not back to that i'm not sure this is
actually just a computer cheat tell me
what i would have never seen on the
computer alejandro so king 37 g6 yeah g6
is what the engine says this might be
for whatever reason and i have no idea
because i mean f5 what if i go to that
drive
okay okay our engine is on zero zero
zero zero some sort of
yeah illicit substance
i mean okay we'll go back to the
we don't think we don't think there's
anything in that one um
a move has been played by dragoon and
actually right now he has uh we know how
much time he has 26 minutes left hi you
play rook f2 instead of rook g2 what a
what a curious decision why why is the
rook on f2
what if i just continue with the small
rook to e3
like what is the point
maybe knight to f3
i don't know maybe he just wants to
bring the king in
king to d5 something like that i don't
know
i and with the rook on g2 you would have
to face bishop to e4 yeah that's power
actually lost
right
no it's definitely lost so this is the
idea that we
assume
camille dragoon is basing his decision
on k2 d5 with arc on g2 would be
impossible because
you also lose this pawn yeah and even
though you get g3 i don't know if it's a
draw because first of all i have a
feeling that i can do this
yeah the engine actually says it's
winning for uh
for white which is not very surprising
yeah
for black
we're winning for white yes sorry
uh king to f2 rook to f3 excuse me
so rook to e3 king to d5 yeah maybe
because at that point you're going to be
reduced to just attacking my queen side
bones there's nothing else you can
really do uh pushing the pawn on the g
on the g file is impossible with a move
like rook e3
so
yeah or something rookie 3 king d5 maybe
or b3 i don't know
hmm
the b3 okay so let's now start with king
to d5 that's our knight c4
yes
rook c3 anyway
i cannot go to c5 because of b3 so i'm
going to go to here but i lose again
because of this move do you lose though
b5 is the only move right a4 and king d4
and what if i continue to take some b2's
check ah that's a check okay so now i
have to take take
this position
and perhaps i'm not too scared of that
right no there's no king activity
actually no you should be scared what
rook to c2
check with the c1
ah and i get my rook behind
yeah but even this is a draw right i
don't know
rook after g1 and c3
uh
so you feel like you have enough uh
activity in the position so i know i
have enough activity okay the position
i don't have to feel anything nobody
else is here
why do you have enough i mean anything
that picks up the a phone and i put my
rook on g8 as a draw
that's a lot of moves how do you do that
i mean king d3 i don't know
it's not that hard
i mean you're one tempo away okay
because now you can actually take and go
yeah if you don't get this then i go to
g4 right yeah yeah yeah then on well
rich before you get yourself made
even this is yeah yeah it's easy yeah
it's too easy yeah black is just a bit
too active so he's actually gone from
rook d1 check instead perhaps because of
this activity not allowing the the move
knight c4
rogue d1 check the king has to go
somewhere a bit awkward because king c5
bishop e4 is not the most pleasant but
you do have knight c4 still this knight
has to hop there you have a threat on b2
you have a threat kind of on a3 big
threat and you have the biggest threat
which is actually knight d2
yep
so actually bishop before my ship if i
might just not be a good move
you still have bishop c2 to defend
bishop c2 you also have rook d5 but i
don't see how the five keys helped me so
much
and by the way while we were discussing
uh this game as we expected though and
abby money did draw their uh game so
that actually takes us to uh all the
results in the a group a draw yeah every
single game was drawn today and by the
way on the game c5 was played
can you see if i was played yeah yes
yeah
yeah that makes a lot of sense because
bishop before it's not dangerous
yeah i i still think this is closer to a
draw than a win for white because of the
activity perfect before we sign off
let's take a look at the game between
burke and zhanchao as well
and actually
nothing absolutely happened nothing has
happened burke is still thinking we see
the nice back spy cam
like what what a shot this is from the
back of the player
behind the wall this is i think my
single favorite this is chess shot we
are definitely staying
we have to we have to keep this one
right this is staying on the broadcast
no matter what happens we're going to
have a spy cam from now on i like the
sky cam bishop d4 so we're thinking like
objectively and by the way no
subjectively which move would you play
actually
i would have started with rook f7 i have
feeling but
all right king b3
and i assume that on rook a7
he might just go with b5 to be honest
but rook to a7 has to be played i don't
think it's a choice if you don't play
rook a7 you might just as well resign i
think so
either that or to b6 but rook to b6 does
make a lot of sense because i have a
feeling rook to a7 just loses the pawn
yep
so since we are about to sign off i'm
going to cheat
wow king a2 actually let go of a huge
amount of the advantage really yeah it's
shocking
so we're talking about this position
yeah when he played the move king to a2
no you're telling me alejandro yes our
viewers and you're not lying to us i
mean
try not to that king to a2 loses a lot
of its advantage tell us why
uh i don't know it just went from 1.5 to
0.5 so that's good enough
that is good commentary i mean i would
have played king a2 in a heartbeat right
yes i play king 2 in a heartbeat i bring
the king to c4 and i think later but
apparently the engine really did not
want to do it they actually wanted to
put the bishop on c4
keep that rook on a8 uh if you play this
apparently just like b3 or something
you don't have a way to defend you don't
have a way to defend this point
eventually and you're not i'm not
getting mated somehow right like bishop
well probably just bishop b5 actually
ah probably yes yeah we should be five
and now rook to a7 is coming and yeah i
agree with that so you go bishop c4 you
force the move rook k8 it's the only
move and now i go f4 and i start f4 and
bishop d4 rook d7 yeah immediately lose
a point ah okay okay okay okay yeah that
makes sense
actually
yeah you're uh just going for the pawn
so
absolutely yeah in fact the last move
before the time control king
very natural by the way it's easy to
make king to a2 um
and we got to this position rook to a7
rook to b5 and as you were mentioning
still
john with decent chances to convert
nevertheless as you uh did mention he
did lose a lot of his advantage now
as we get ready to sign off let's take a
look at the standings
after five rounds uh in fact results we
have received results in the a group
look at that bunch of results all of
them draws no changes in the standings
meanwhile in the b group we do have a
couple of changes as christopher yu does
take a full point against brandon
jacobson by forfeit no change in rating
there and tigran had union who's having
a really rough event here uh is lost
with the white pieces against misha
antipov uh jj alimorand is playing as
camille dragon we expect that that's
closer to a draw but it's going to be a
long fight and john burke who also is
probably closer now to a draw than to a
win
is still with a fighting advantage uh
against jojon ciao trying to get that
full point he's a little bit more stuck
than he would like to be uh but
certainly with the press here in the
same game no absolutely a lot of fun uh
games today very technical i have to say
it felt like today now final thoughts
from uh you about this round six
alejandro i think it was great a little
bit unfortunate of course that we had to
uh lose a player uh
no don't spray fake news anywhere if we
don't know if it's covered or not we do
know he's sick yeah so he did have to
withdraw for health reasons but we don't
know if it's go but we it might not be
uh but unfortunately he did have to
withdraw for health reasons and because
it was past the halfway mark remember
that his remaining opponents will get
his full point that is a huge difference
from the a group so a little unfortunate
there uh the a group was incredibly
unexciting today which is a bit
unfortunate because we had some great
matchups
i mean i never really expected much from
glendora jacobian great players of
course great fighters they do go to the
same university and they know each other
like the back of their fans so uh they
didn't have any interest in playing each
other yeah and meanwhile i was really
hoping that union yi savion was going to
be a fire burner of course it wasn't it
wasn't this kind of iron okay he tried
against mishra but mishar just continues
impressing just incredible chess
neutralizes his mature hiring the player
without any issues yeah in a very
dangerous and sharp line that line with
g4 essay by oparin a fun round
nevertheless we will be back tomorrow
with round number seven the tournament
continues and you can of course reach us
at hashtag summerchestclassic to ask us
any question during the event but also
after the event is over and we will be
seeing you tomorrow same time same place
3 30 p.m central time with myself and
alejandro see you guys tomorrow see you
then join us for round seven
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited